so right now we're partnering with a
really fascinating project called
cold stack and they're doing some really
cool things in the world of cloud
storage in particular decentralized
cloud storage i want to tell you what
they're up to
how they're changing what's possible
when it comes to storing your files on
decentralized cloud networks and what
else they have
on the horizon so to start with
centralized
cloud storage most of us are familiar
with it many of us use it
daily weekly amazon web services
google cloud google drive you're paying
a company to store your data
on a centralized server but with
decentralized cloud storage the data is
distributed into different
pieces and stored in different
nodes of a peer-to-peer network and
there's many advantages
to the decentralization of cloud storage
more security because decentralized
storage platforms break apart user files
and distribute them across the network
and because the data scattered across
multiple nodes
there's no single point of failure your
files
being broken apart like this also means
more privacy because it's harder
to assemble that data back together and
decentralized networks are also
excellent for storing cold data meaning
data that's rarely used
but has to be stored a long time which
makes up about 60
of the world's data in fact so there are
a lot of different benefits to storing
data on a decentralized network like
this
but there are also some huge problems
facing the decentralized cloud storage
industry right now people have trouble
integrating them with their own systems
it can be expensive to get involved with
decentralized cloud storage networks can
be difficult to combine
and it's also difficult to switch
between them and a lot of this
is because there's no programming
interfaces
that unify all of the biggest
decentralized cloud
networks so developers can't reuse
existing tools to build on to what other
developers have already done
so these are the problems in essence
that cold stack is trying to solve
cold stack is an aggregator of all
decentralized clouds that already exist
and
cold stack thinks of themselves sort of
as the uber
for cloud storage cold stack lets
companies migrate from services like
amazon to decentralized clouds
with really what's just two clicks and
this lets users
save money when storing data it allows
users to save time and
effort when onboarding switching
combining these clouds
and there's no need for data migration
when you're switching between clouds
everything just stays really simple
there's a unified programming interface
and it makes things really easy for
developers as well
the cold stack ai selects the best cloud
to fit a user's needs and to optimize
the final storage cost
in an all-in-one platform and coldstack
is also 100 compatible with
amazon s3 api which is going to be
really useful for a lot of people
because it will allow any project
already using the amazon library or the
sdk
to quickly scale up and start using cold
stack with very little effort
and it also has a built-in option to
tokenize any file you've uploaded so you
can turn your files into nfts
and it has a universal digital asset
storage
for any nft marketplace so like i
mentioned
decentralized clouds especially good for
storing cold data
that's what cold stack does really well
and cold stack can do it for a fraction
of the cost
so let's really look at the advantages
of cold stack
over other clouds and also how they
price their services let's say you're a
company
for one year you need to store a million
files that are each one kilobyte
and also 10 000 files which are each one
gigabyte
during that year you're downloading
about 20
of those files our weave would cost you
about a hundred and ninety thousand
dollars our weave stores data
permanently which has advantages
but the cost can really add up for large
files
sia would cost you about fifteen hundred
dollars
amazon glacier would be about eight
hundred and two dollars and
cold stack would be only four hundred
dollars
cold stacks ai pipeline finds the best
storage service
for every bit of data that a user
uploads
and this is what allows it to be half
the cost of amazon glacier
so i would encourage uh everyone to
check out
the cold stack website you can read more
about how the ecosystem works you can
read the light paper
they actually have a great live demo
where you can upload some test files
from your computer
see how the cold stack interface works
you can check out the road map to see
how they're getting to the final product
launch near the end of this year and
there's some really
interesting partnerships you can look at
as well cold stack is a project
i'm keeping an eye on it'll be
interesting to see everything as it
rolls
out over the course of this year and the
decentralized cloud storage industry
altogether has a market cap
of about five billion dollars all around
decentralized cloud storage is an
interesting space to follow
data storage is a very cool application
of blockchain technology
and i've put the link to the cold stack
website in the description of this video
for you to check out what they're up to
as always with any project with anything
that involves finances with anything
that involves money
i'm not making any endorsement or
suggestion that anybody
invest in any particular way i'm telling
you about the project as i see it
and everybody should be doing all due
diligence before making
any financially impactful decision